hey guys and welcome to episode 95 I
believe this is a pretty cool episode
because I actually got some stuff done
and I was really positively surprised at
the moment others actually worked out
like before I did this I didn't do this
in a stream I decided last couple of
streams didn't really work out it was
all fun and games but didn't really get
too much good stuff done and I really
needed to move on and work towards
actually finishing this touch area so I
made a couple of really simple custom
scenery pieces like there was nothing
whatsoever it took barely any time
really simple stuff but it actually
helped out a great deal on making this
station the first one being a very
simple cornerstone that was too sort of
made for the front facade since the
others the other corner stones from the
ralphie's didn't really work out too
well they were pretty damn large and the
other pieces were just to create these
ironwork arches and that's basically the
entire idea of this station like I've
mentioned before it's a typical Dutch
station although I did get some
recommendations for other Dutch stations
but I feel like this is the most
recognizable sort of form now obviously
many different sorts of stations that
you can do but there was one architect I
completely forgot his name I'm very
sorry about that but yeah he made the
stations which would usually feature
this style I think he even designed the
Museum in Amsterdam but it's that's that
same sort of Panamint and with two
towers style but I also really wanted to
have some of that classical train
station ironworks and Glaus well behind
that for the station itself which is
quite a common thing relief seen it in
many German stations as well and it does
also have a bit of a steampunk slash
Victorian feel to it and I really just
wanted to get that in only problem is
there aren't really any sort of objects
using which you can do that very well I
was considering maybe using mobis but
mobis does Mobe does I mean I'm talking
about movies but I mean volumes I was
very stupid um he does have that one set
which has I think it's yeah it's called
Goda's and glass which does have round
cross pieces using what you could build
a similar sort of thing
but it really doesn't have the same sort
of arch since I really wanted a subtle
arts that didn't rise too much just
about 1h on spread over two tiles was
the height that I was looking for so how
to get that made because as far as I
know that isn't really anything like
that but even though they're really
really simple pieces with really simple
textures as well it really did work out
fairly well on the end so that's really
awesome but that does mean though that
at the moment you can't really recreate
the train station in the way that it is
currently it's the the pike still needs
to be finished for that and I still need
to release the custom sceneries for that
so I'm sorry about that
but I suppose if you really want to have
them I could upload a current version of
the set but I don't know how good that
would be there's no thumbnails there's
barely any pieces in it and it's pretty
terrible at the moment so yeah that's
probably gonna have to wait at until
some other time but yeah the basic idea
over here was just to get the simple
ironed work framework done before I
moved on to the other things this is
obviously going to have that glass roof
again in the end it's just much easier
especially if you have these framework
roofs so this works with Iron Works but
also with the Polynesian sort of theme
it's very good to just build the frame
first be able to see what you're going
to do in the interior and then put the
roof on later just it's not that
important but it kind of helps in
building things so that's why I decided
to do this like this also I did want to
do quite a bit of it's not fully
interior since it's still sort of inside
it's still sort of I mean it's still
sort of outside it's not completely
inside a building but I did want to get
some interior ish things on this little
station some little benches lights of
course which these hanging baskets don't
exactly fits but I feel like that good
enough might also want to make something
for that but I think it's just about
acceptable they just have a bit of a
very awkward placement over there like
if they were moved say 10 centimeters to
the right or the left that would have
been even better but oh well it's not
not much that you can do about that
honestly I still need to finish that
pediment as well still need to get some
some sort of good window for that and I
don't know how many pieces I really want
to make for this thing
so far it has sort of worked out but as
too much unreleased accustomed scenery
in this building and I'm not really a
big fan of that but yeah in any case
it's gonna be a pretty sort of very
simple and standard train station with
just two rails going through it I think
that the other side of it would be for
the English area not entirely sure how I
would even make that work since usually
the steam Park trains would just have
one rail even in the station but it
looks good to have this other rail and
it might also be good to add a tiny
connection around the back that would
give you like a fast connection into the
english area without having to walk
around this entire building and cross
the the rail itself so might want to do
that though I'm not really sure yet how
I'm going to do that and this by the way
was just a tiny bit of work I just
figured hey I can get some some of these
details in just opening you know
sometimes you really have that you just
open it custom scenery set and you feel
like it's actually has some good pieces
in here that I could use for this in
this area and that's just sort of how I
felt about that it did have some some of
those rope pieces and since I did have
those hanging ropes on top of all the
cables in the Dutch area that just
seemed like the perfect fit that I could
fit in there which it was I have to say
that was really good
so I was pretty happy to get that in and
really other than this I don't think
there really was anything else to the
train station
yeah the glass roof but other than that
it's pretty simple that I do have to say
that at this point in time I still
haven't finished the interior details on
the side of the entrance with the two
towers which is still very empty just
walls and nothing else at the moment I
mean they could use some nice lights and
benches and maybe a ticket booth on the
side even if it's just for show it would
be pretty nice but not something like
I'm gonna have to get into later but
yeah that is pretty much the station
itself finished I think yeah I just
wanted to have the small building to the
side
I think the station in The Hague has
this the station in Amsterdam has much
larger wings but on this station is
definitely not going to be as large
there was a bit of a scale problem if I
wanted to do this right because the
usual station is quite a bit larger than
just
so it is a bit of a minute Ave a
miniature version of its real-life
counterparts but for being that I
suppose that it all works out
alright I'm not going to complain about
this because I've got I've been
complaining about my own thing about too
many times though I would like to
probably say something about that
I like to find a balance between not
being happy about what you've built and
looking back at what you've built and
being happy about it oh it sounds very
vague I'm gonna try to sort of explain
that whenever you build something you
know you can you can go two ways in the
way that you feel it at least I feel
about it at least two extreme ways can
always be balanced which is what would
be best but if you don't feel too good
about something that you've built you're
motivated to change it to change it for
the better improve it and improve your
skills on building overall which is
something that I would always try to do
like you should not ever be happy about
everything that you've ever built like
it's always good to look at what you've
built and feel like that I there is room
for improvement and not just be like hey
that's good I built good things and
let's move on since that's basically how
you improve but then again I don't think
there really is any point to doing all
of this other than looking back at what
you've built and being happy about what
you've built because that's also part of
the fun being able to look back at your
stuff and just have fun looking back at
it so that's also something that I would
definitely want to have so I always
tried to find the balance between being
happy about some things and being able
to look back at them and enjoy it but
also think about some things which I'm
not too certain about and see if there's
any way to improve them which might come
off as annoying in my videos I'm sorry
about that but I Villages it's not very
it's not even that much of a
perfectionistic tendency I just really
want to find room for improvement
wherever I go since you can never be
perfect at anything so yeah that's
pretty much that though that being said
if you were to perfectionistic you can
go on building stuff forever so that's
also not a good idea
this was the little exit or entrance
whatever you will it goes both ways of
the England area but
still not too sure what I can even and
in that and at that point I figured that
this area needed more life not much more
since I only added a couple of simple
flower boxes and some simple signs it's
really not that much yet it is really
hard to make this area look alive I
really need more signs maybe call
curtains behind the windows with that
it's gonna be a tiny bit harder to do
and things like that and just getting
those signs of life is pretty damn hard
to make it work might want to get more
hanging baskets in and stuff because if
nothing works then foliage is always an
amazing way to make things look alive at
least that's how I always like to look
at it but these buildings are still
somewhat unfinished you could still see
some doors with glass windows in them
don't worry they will be removed at some
point in the future and replaced with
doors that don't show the brick wall
behind the doors because that's very
awkward speaking of awkwardly flags
didn't really work out there so I
figured I would have a flag on that made
little square give that square bit or
they used as well but that's a bit
that's a tiny bit off-topic it is that
the building's itself they have that
door there's also the side walls that I
still need to finish and of course the
extra details and then okay so I see
that I'm running out of time so yeah
that's gonna be its but today thank you
guys for watching and see you space
cowboys